thương báo hoạt động kìm chá sĩ đưa tổ chức định kiế bật ám dựa sản thân ngày thứ 3 và thứ 5 toàn trường ngày lấy,
bắt đầu tương ngày 20, sau đến hếm nềm miệch in hàng bài, đề điểm tổ chức kìm chá cả trụ sở đổi sắp hạnh,
tập giấy phép lại xe, cơ dựa đường bộ, thu phòng cạnh giác sợ thông cơ man thành quá hả nội,
để chỉ số 2 phung hơn, phường hả nội. Phòng cạnh giác sợ thông thành quá nội lâu ý, người thăm xa kìm chà,
cân có mặt đúng thời sản về điểm được thông báo để hoàn tất cả tụ tu cân thiết.
Khi đến sự kiểm tra người dân phải mang theo các dây tổ thuy thân và giấy phép lại xe,
còn hiệu lực để cơ quan chức năng đổi chiều xác mình thông tin.
Bây giờ, tu trước các đợt kiểm tra phục hồi điểm, giấy phép lại xe không chỉ tạo điều kiện cho người dân.
Khá phục các vị phạm chức đó mà còn có phần nân cảm nhận thốc ý,
thương chấp hành phó luật về ra thông đự bộ.
Thông qua quá trình 1 tập và kìm chà kinh thức người điều khiến phúc kiện có cơ hội cập nhật các quy định mới,
tôi đau nân cơ kỹ năng thăm xa ra thông an toàn hạnh chiến quyết cơ vi phạm và tài nạn xa thông.
Phòng cạnh giác sợ thông cơ mang thành phó nội cũng khuyến nghiệm người dân có nho cầu phục hồi điểm,
giấy phép lại xe, chú đọng theo só để kìm chà, chừng bị đầy đủ dễ tầu cần thiết và điểm đúng thời sản quy định,
để quá trình kìm chà diễn sạch thật lời.